reçoit docteur cécile tremblay
microbiologiste-infectiologue au centre
hospitalier de l'université de montréal
donc le chum bonsoir de quoi trembler
par ce moment qu'elle avait entendu la
ministre la santé dit on travaille alors
fait les bilans pour voiler chiffre
monte en même temps ce dimanche ils
doivent les traiter avec quoi est-ce
qu'on traite les personnes atteintes que
ce soit la boétie est ce qu on doit ce
qu'il faut mais en fait il ya pas de
traitements antiviraux actifs contre le
virus n'a à notre connaissance
présentement ce qu'ils ont fait en chine
c'est que dès le début de l'épidémie
ils ont commencé des essais cliniques
avec des anciennes anti-bayrou qu'on
utilise pour d'autres maladies qui
pourraient avoir eu un petit peu
d'effets sur les symptômes lors de
l'épidémie du sras ce puits ont décidé
d'étudier ces médicaments là dans des
essais cliniques sur ces populations là
pour voir si on pourra voir un petit
bénéfice à d utiliser parallèlement à
cela il ya des efforts qui sont faits
pour développer des antiviraux qui sera
efficace mais ça c'est un processus qui
est très à long terme là les chansons
qu'on aura pas de médicaments efficaces
contre le virus
l'épidémie va se terminer avant qu'on
ait un médicament efficace alors les
soins qu'on donne ce sont des ce qu'on
appelle des soins de support finalement
on aide les gens ce qu'ils sont en
détresse respiratoire en les aidant
respirer avec des ventilateurs en les
hydratant correctement supportant leur
pression artérielle
c'est ce qu'on appelle des soins de
support parfois ils vont soit êtres
amsif ceux qui ont des maladies légère
ils peuvent très bien passé à travers à
la maison et de dire qu on est un peu
des témoins impuissants
je dirais pas un puissant parce que même
dans le cas de maladie sévère comme on a
vu le taux de létalité donc la mortalité
attribuable à ce virus là elle n'est que
de 2%
le temps du strass c'était au tour de
disposant donc ce traitement de support
que l'on fait ça marche ça fonctionne
pour la majorité des gens en même temps
on apprenait ce matin que le médecin qui
a lancé l'alerté aux états unis ce
médecin avait été déclaré mort en cours
de journée on a dit qu'il n'était pas
mort finalement et c'est le docteur lil
wayne lang se nomme tellement légiste on
le voit là l'écran parce qu'il y avait
mis
il y avait même posté son visage sur les
réseaux sociaux 34 ans finalement il est
décédé
ça illustre le risque que courent tous
les travailleurs de la santé sur la
ligne de front comme un one
oui on fait lors de l'épidémie du sras
ce les premières victimes avaient été
les travers de la santé parce qu'on ne
connaissait pas le virus on savait
possède transmissibilité les gens ont
été pris au dépourvu
cette fois ci on a une longueur d'avancé
parce que on ne sut dès les premières
semaines de l'épidémie en chine qu'il y
avait un risque les travers de la santé
puis déjà des précautions qui ont été
mis en place
là-bas mais un peu tardivement faire
diversion le dollar mais aussi par la
police puis considéré mâle 10 ans à
l'état alors que nous ici au canada on a
déjà en place toutes ces précautions là
pour protéger travers de la santé on
isole les patients suspects il ya tout
un attirail de prévention comporte
je suis laissé dire mais je vérifie avec
vous que on donne quand même certains
médicaments qu'on donne aux personnes
atteintes du vih est ce que c'est vrai
c'est un des essais cliniques qu'ils
étudient en chine c'était un des
antirétroviraux un des anciens
antirétroviraux qu'on utilisait parce
que il avait utilisé sa lors l'épidémie
du sras ce pays avait noté que des
symptômes peut-être un peu moins sévère
mais ce n'est pas une vraie étude
randomisée qui démontrait quoi que ce
soit fait que ce soit en dehors on va le
tester on revoit ça peut aider
puis un autre médicament qui était
développé contre les mollahs par la
compagnie
leur haine des spires qu'ils essaient
aussi qu'ils étudient pour voir ça peut
aider ça peut avoir un effet mis à part
les sponsors si ça devait arriver là
parce que de nouveaux cas je prends en
colombie-britannique sont confirmées si
je me trompe pas en dernière heure avant
d'entrer en ondes en avait ça on les
traite avec des soins de support mais ce
qu'on irait on utiliserait les antilles
il faudra voir si l'évidence vaut la
peine de supporter ça c'est sûr que
quelqu'un en fin de course on n'hésite
pas à utiliser tous on peut utiliser
même si on n'a pas la preuve on sait que
ces médicaments ne sont pas les fastes
pour le corps humain et donc on pourrait
presque depuis le début d'épidémie en
musique sont les personnes sur tout âge
et les personnes vulnérables
immunodéprimées est-ce que je mettrais
non parce que le médecin est avec 34 ans
n'ont en fait la majorité des gens qui
sont infectés par ce virus là ne sont
pas des personnes âgées avec beaucoup de
coureurs ministre l'âge moyen autour de
59 ans avec un rire jaune à un très
vieux à peu près 30% des gens ont des
comorbidités mais ça affecte des
personnes jeunes des jeunes adultes des
adultes avec moi essayons de leur
habileté particulière nécessairement
versement aurait pas pour être un fake
nommé pour mourir pour mourir
c'est sûr que si on a des comorbidités
si on est très malade
au départ on a moins de capacité de
défendre puis on a plus de chances
d'avoir un résultat
un négatif alors on travaille bien sur
un avocat aux etats-unis ou en
grande-bretagne avait des laboratoires
qui se mobiliser pour faire des études
vous avez tout à l'heure ça va être à la
fin de l'épidémie parce que ça va nous
donner quelque chose peut-être dans six
mois un an d'avoir trouvé un vaccin pour
la prochaine crise tout à fait parce que
lors du strass les études ont commencé
tardivement pour essayer de trouver le
vaccin ça prend du temps avant qu'on ait
la séquence du virus et à la toute fin
il avait des candidats au vaccin qu'il
voulait commencer à étudier que
l'épidémie s'est terminée par ils ont
laissé sur la glace il n'a pas été
développé pour être commercialisés et
donc cessé même d'accès est là qu on
utilise qui sont en train de développer
à vitesse grand v présentement pour voir
avec en changeant le lay rennes virale
pour celui de ce corps aux norovirus là
pour voir si on pourrait pas l'utiliser
dans le cadre de cette épidémie
les premiers essais cliniques de phase 1
vont être en avril donc en phase 1 c'est
juste pour voir si sécuritaire et puis
un petit peu d'efficacité chez les gens
puis après ça s'apprend des études de
plus grande ampleur donc c'est pas sûr
que ça va être réaliste de penser qu'on
va avoir un vaccin avant la fin de
l'épidémie parce qu'on souhaite que les
mesures pas si longtemps que ça valait
ce périmètre en veste et passionnant
merci de nous avoir éclairé
merci